the midterms are first and foremost
about Congress and they can make or
break a president's agenda
Republican control of both the House of
Representatives and the Senate has made
Trump's life relatively easy so far but
if Democrats flip one or even both
houses the good times may be over the
entire house all 435 seats are up for
election and they are every two years
Republicans currently hold 235 to
Democrats 193 seats that's a lot of
distance to the 218 majority mark but
Democrats hope that the slew of
Republicans leaving their seats this
year along with enough anti-trump fury
among voters will deliver them the house
so all eyes are on the 30 or so toss-ups
race is that polling data have is too
close to call on the Senate side
Republicans rule with the slimmest of
majorities 51 of 100 seats sounds like
good news for Democrats but only 35
seats of those are up for election most
26 are ones Democrats and independents
allied with them need to defend that
makes victory harder polling data
suggests maybe just six seats in all our
toss ups as the minority party Democrats
have been limited in effectively
resisting Trump but what if they win in
both the House and Senate they could
block his agenda and introduce their own
they could investigate the myriad
allegations of abuse and misconduct
facing Trump in the Senate Democrats
could reject Trump appointees up for
important positions and they could
impeach a long and fraught process that
starts in the house and ends in the
Senate Democrats have history on their
side as the president's party usually
suffers in the midterms whether that
trend stays true won't be clear until
ballots are in
you